Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to. Oh,
I don't know. It's just it's the phone
lines are just packed, folks. Packed. Let's
go to Eric from Philly. Eric from Philly.
Welcome to the program. What's going on?
And you got to unmute yourself. There you go.
Speaker 2: I mean, sorry about that.
Um, thank you very much. I knew you were going
to pick me things that went to the drive thru.
Okay. Quick question for you, please. Do you think
Republicans are going with the arming teachers
argument because they think it's a go
nowhere issue? Because I really don't believe
society is going to be okay with arming it.
Speaker 1: I actually I don't know. I mean,
I think that there are private schools that there
might even be some private schools that have done
it and maybe some that will. But I do think you're
right that as a matter of public schools, teachers
aren't going to be armed any time soon. And part
of what Republicans need is any time somebody like
me proposes, you know, ten different things we
could do about gun safety. They say no to all
of them. And some of those Republicans and right
wingers and gun people would like to at least be
able to pretend that they're offering something as
opposed to just saying no. And so I think part of
what you're suspecting is correct, which is they
go, well, let's arm teachers and let's lock the
doors or whatever just so they can say, we're
not saying do nothing. Here's what we want to
do. And of course, they're never really going to
have to legislate it because public schools at I
would never say never. Eric has never is a long
time, but at any time soon, we are not going to
see teachers armed at public schools.
Speaker 2: All right. Thanks for
entering my question. I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. Eric from Philly,
thank you very much. Great to hear from you. Why
don't we go next to Cesar from Florida? Cesar
from Florida. Welcome to the program. What's
on your mind today? Caesar, please. Cesar,
I'm guessing you have the wrong audio device
selected. Now, boy. That's really too bad.